okay today I'm going to talk to you
about neurons now neurons are just type
of specialized cell within the nervous
system that allow transmission of
electrical signals there's three types
of neuron we're going to learn about but
all have different structures sensory
neurons motor neurons and relay neurons
so we're going to start off with sensory
neurons so a sensory neuron will be
involved whenever you have an organ
which can sense something so whenever
you touch smell see hear or taste
something that starts off at these
things called receptors for example you
have receptors in your skin that allow
you to feel things and you have
receptors in the retina of your eye that
allow you to detect light so what we
have here is all of these neurons have a
cell body now the cell body is where the
nucleus is and this is the cytoplasm so
it's kind of like a normal animal cell
but only with these other features so
this part here before the cell body is
called a dendron so receptors is where
what what detects the signal in the
first place let's say I touch something
the electrical impulses travel down the
dendron past the cell body and to
probably somewhere within the central
nervous system for example a part of my
brain that allows me to to have the
sensation that I'm touching something
this part here is called an axon so an
axon is just the long part here where
the electrical signal travels down a
good way of remembering it is axons
always travel away the signal always
travels away from the cell body
dendrites always take or dendrites
always take information towards a cell
body in this particular case the limb
postie let's go impulsive traveling that
way down okay so that's a sensory neuron
involved in sensation or feeling things
being able to sense things
number two is motor neurons
now motor neurons
and normally what we associate with
movement but not always for example they
can be attached to glands as well but
motor neurons are a bit different in
structure so at the beginning they have
a cell body rather than having receptors
for example this could be within the
central nervous system within the brain
let's say what it then has is this long
part here just like within the sensor in
your run that long part is called an
axon that are labeled in just a second
ok so just finish drawing this so this
long protrusion is called an axon so
let's say I want to move my finger these
dendrites first of all they carry
electrical impulses towards the cell
body so this is me wanting to move my
finger the electrical impulse this this
cell will be within the brain this cell
body the brain then the electrical
impulse will travel down the axon so
this thing here the muscle in my finger
and in this particular scenario the
muscle is referred to as an effector
this is just where the effect happens
the effect is to contract my muscle to
move it now
these those things there are called
dendrites remember dendrites take
electrical impulses towards the cell
body axon a is for axon a is for
electrical impulses away from the cell
body so the impulse is traveling down
that way
now the final thing we need to know
about motor neurons is they have these
things called a myelin sheath nice way
of remembering it it's Emmis for motor
Ms for myelin M is usually to do with
movement and is usually to do with
muscle so the myelin sheath insulates
the axon so we get nice fast
transmission for example Stephen Hawking
he had a disease called motor neuron
disease where the myelin sheath broke
down which means he imposes could not
travel down to his muscles meaning he
couldn't move however his sensory
neurons were fine so he could still see
and he could still touch and you can
still hear because these types of
neurons were fine they don't have my
think motor Milan the third type of
neuron and final type of neuron we need
to know about is a relay neuron
now the way I always remember the job of
a relay neuron is I think about a relay
race in a relay race a baton is passed
from one runner to the next if relay
neurone takes information from one
neuron to the next so what we have again
is we have these protrusions coming out
called dendrites now these dendrites
would be attached to sensory neurons
what we then have again that long
protrusion hopefully by now we know that
that's called an axon so this is where
the electrical signal passes down we
then have these connections here which
can then pass the signal on just like in
a relay race it can then pass that
signal on to a motor neuron so just to
put that into context let's say in a
reflex arc I put my hand on something
apart that would be detected by these
receptors in a sensory neuron and the
information would travel down here to
sew down this down draw down the axon to
a relay niall run one of these that
information would then go from the
dendrite towards the cell body down the
axon and then it would connect to a mote
in your run the information would travel
down the dendrite towards the cell body
then down this axon to the muscle in
order to move my finger away from this
stimulus that was causing it harm so
those are the three types of neuron
that's how they all look different from
each other that's their different jobs
and functions and that is all I'm going
to say on it thank you